In compliance with chapter 551 open
meetings of the Texas Government Code, I
call to order a regular voting meeting
of the board of trustees of the Austin
Independent School District for
Thursday, October 30th, 2025 at 6:01
p.m. A quorum of the board is physically
present at the Austin ISD central office
to conduct this meeting. This meeting is
being broadcast on cable channel 22
through Spectrum is down broadband and
on channel 99 through AT&T Iverst close
captioning in in English is available on
these platforms for individuals who are
deaf or heart of hearing. Welcome and
thank you for joining us. We will begin
with public testimony for items on our
consent agenda. Members of the public
wishing to participate in the public
testimony portion of our meeting called
a dedicated AISD phone line in adv
advance of the meeting to sign up to
speak in person or to audio record their
remarks. Tonight we have three people
who signed up to speak in person and we
have nine people who left a recorded
message. Uh we will now to move to
inerson testimony to provide as many
opportunities for input as possible
within a limited time period at this
meeting. Each speaker will be allotted
one minute. No substitutions or yielding
of time to others is permitted. Uh you
are welcome to come to the microphone
when your name is called. As you come to
the microphone, please press the button
to turn it on. There's a device that
will light up as you move through your
one minute of time. When the buzzer
sounds, please make a final thought in
one sentence. And we ask that whether
you come to give a complaint or praise
that you reference any staff member by
position or abbreviated last name. And
we ask that all audience members,
whether speaking or not, please show
respect for others at all times. And our
in-person speakers for tonight are Edna
Par, Leah Kelly, and Jared Schroed.
Yeah. If Ednan's not here, then Jared
Schroed and Leah Kelly. Is Edna here
also? Yeah. Any order. It doesn't
matter. Thank you.
Hello. Okay. Thank you. Uh my name is
Edna Parara and I'm a longtime East
Austin resident and parent. Um AISD
recently shared that it has identified
five underutilized properties and
completed a portfolio evaluation to see
which might be declared um surplus land.
Um while the document doesn't say which
sites are under review, it signals that
some campuses may already be evaluated
for closure or sale without full
transparency.
It's likely those details will be shared
later, but the lack of transparency with
this and across the TAP plan
consolidation process and budget
discussions along with contracts like
this again is concerning. At yesterday's
meeting um at Maplewood with
Superintendent Sigura and team, it was
unclear what um it was it was clear that
communication on budgets uh academic
decisions um and uh transparency in
general has been inconsistent
and nothing has been academically um
focused and uh especially when
presenting any of these consolidation
plans. Um, Campbell parents also said
that they hadn't been contacted at all
despite being directly impacted. Merging
Maplewood with Campbell with Campbell, a
historically black school, risks
displacing black families and
destabilizing two thriving East Austin
campuses. Um, Austin um 60% of Maplewood
parents said that they already looking
at uh charter schools or public schools,
which is fewer students, fewer dollars,
and less stability for AISD.
Um, I hope that they do a comprehensive
public assessment showing how these real
estate decisions align with the
district's budget, academic goals, and
long-term planning.
>> And do you mind um finishing your
thought on emailing the rest of it to us
so we can
>> Yes. And thank you.
>> Yes. Thank you. Um and I hope that um
that all staff members and all teams
genuinely engage both communities um to
develop a transparent, equitable plan.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
Hi. Is the microphone excellent still
working?
Hi, my name is Leah Kelly, parent to an
Austin High School graduate, partner to
an AISD teacher, and former AISD
employee. Speaking on agenda item 10.1,
I want to thank the district for
potentially partnering with community
providers to expand comprehensive health
supports for students. By working
together, we can increase our capacity
to care for children and families
navigating complex situations.
These services have made a real
difference in my own family's life by
helping my child reach her full
potential. [cough and clears throat]
These partnerships help create more
supportive school environments for
students and staff. The commitment to
spend Proposition A dollars as
communicated to voters provides much
needed transparency is an and is an
important step to reestablishing trust.
[clears throat]
Please vote in favor of agenda item 10.1
and thank you for your dedication to
student well-being, especially during
the difficult situation that we find
ourselves in now.
>> Thank you.
>> [clears throat]
>> Is this on? Oh, it is. Perfect. Um, I'm
speaking on two items. How do is that is
that okay?
>> Uh, it's fine to speak on two items. Do
we have one minute to speak on two? One
minute. So, yeah,
>> two separate minutes, it sounds like.
>> Oh, two separate minutes. Yes. So, two
minutes, one each. Thank you.
>> Perfect.
>> Yes.
>> Um,
I will start on I believe it is 11.1,
which is in regards to the RFP for the
commercial real estate. Uh it was
released this this RFP was released
about 6 to 8 weeks before the school
consolidation list. Uh making it appear
that closures were already known but
intentionally excluded to avoid public
attention which we all know erodess
trust which we don't want. Since 2016
ASD has always named specific properties
in its real estate RFPs. This is the
first time in nearly a decade that the
district has not done that. Currently,
AISD owns nine properties totaling 233
acres of undeveloped land that could be
sold today. When Superintendent Sigura
was authorized to negotiate the Rosedale
sale, AISD sold is selling this for $26
million. Gap 1. Also saving $1.6 million
in commissions if we are not including
real estate brokers. That obviously we
understand that you guys have the
opportunity to do this yourself and stop
closing schools.
if one second. Basically, let's not
impact 70,000 students. Let's not impact
their families. Let's stop closing
schools. Let's sell current acreage that
we already have that isn't developed to
stop our funding gap. Secondly, uh there
is a another contract that is out for no
uh Novium. Um, while I understand this
is not Superintendent Sigura's company,
I do understand that at one point
Sigura, Superintendent Sigura, you
disclosed a relationship and shared
investments with this owner. Given that,
is there a conflict of interest and
should we look at this and discuss this
more versus actually voting on something
like this and giving them $20 million in
a turnaround plan and other things that
you have? I fully recommend that you
guys look into this and continue to
investigate what we're looking at and
who that money is going to. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Um and thank you to our
speakers. And now we will play our
recorded messages for public comment.
>> Hello, my name is Belinda Montgomery. I
am a former parent, current community
member, and former SHAK member in AISD.
I'm calling to get support for agenda
item 10.1 for action on the mental
health services RFP. Our students and
families need timely access to support.
Approving this recommendation will help
schools respond early, reduce crises,
improve attendance, and keep students
learning. Please vote yes on the mental
health services RFP, and continue to
invest in support that reflects
community priorities. We really
appreciate your service. Thank you so
much and have a good day.
>> This is Sharon Bain, parent of two AISP
graduates, and I'm calling to support
agenda item 10.1 for action on the
mental health services RFP. Now more
than ever, our students and families
need timely access to support. Approving
this item will help schools respond
early, reduce crises, improve
attendance, and keep students learning.
Please vote yes and continue to invest
in supports that reflect community
priorities. Thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Richard Kelly. I am a
product of AISD until very recently, a
parent of a student in AISD and I am in
my 24th year as a teacher in AISD. And
I'm calling to express my support,
there's the bell, um for agenda item
10.1
uh on the mental health services RFP. I
can tell you as somebody who's in
classes uh classrooms every day with
your students um the mental health needs
could not be higher. Uh this has
accelerated so much in the last five or
six years. And so I really want to
encourage the board to approve this RFP
um for increased mental health services
which is going to help uh reduce crises,
improve attendance, and of course help
students learn. So, please vote yes on
the mental health services RFP and
continue to invest in supports that
reflect our community's priorities and
quite frankly what your students need.
Thank you for your services.
>> Hello, my name is Amy Garrett and I'm a
parent of two students in South Austin.
I'm calling to support agenda item 10.1
for action on the mental health services
RFP. Our students and families need
timely access to support and approving
this recommendation will help schools
respond early, support students, and
keep them learning. Please vote yes on
the mental health services RFP and
continue to invest in supports that
reflect our community priorities.
Um, it's important to note that this
contract was already allowed for and
voted for by Prop A. Um, I just want to
continue to make sure that those funds
are allocated appropriately. Um, thank
you all trustees for your continued
service to the district. I know this,
um,
last six months have been very hard.
Thank you so much for your efforts.
Thanks,
>> Marie Parent. Um, 5.1 closures and
consolidations. Give it more time. 5.3,
please address HQ spending, legal fees
and lawsuits, and staffing at HQ. We
should not be suing neighborhoods or
teacher staffing vendors or children
with disabilities. 6.1 I have personally
been to Mendes several times. I do not
find 200 or 300 children at Mendes.
Please look into the numbers and data
being reported as well as the practices
at Mendes. Um do not renew with Third
Future. It's time to take Mendes back as
our own school. 10.1 on the mental
health contract. Grammarc was
ineffective at best. Please do not
consider them. 10.2 Two, amend the
budget to reduce HQ spending and
staffing. We need to reduce the staffing
at HQ. Seek alternative solutions for
leasing, selling, or lease back of HQ.
And we need a review and oversight of
legal fees. 12.1. There's not sufficient
data posted to meet open information act
requirements on this item and some of
the others. Only a list of names is
visible in board docs for 12.1. They
13.2. Thank you for declining.
Thanks.
Uh yes, this is Patrick Rosenthal and I
am calling about the agenda item 8.1
approval of the IB statement of
acceptance for Anderson High. Please
accept that statement. Also, schools on
the closure list deserve a chance to
look at all available options. Being on
a list doesn't mean a school is beyond
hope. It means it needs thoughtful
consideration and collaboration. There
may be solutions that benefit not just
one campus but the entire district.
Innovative partnerships, shared
programs, or creative use of space that
keep communities strong. The AISD
employees, students, and families across
the district are counting on you, the
trustees, to get this right. Please look
at every option, listen to every
community, and ensure that all voices
are heard, even from those schools
facing closure. The AISD employees are
burning the candle at both ends. They
will do the work for small changes in
the plan if you allow them to look into
them. Thank you.
>> Uh my name is Greg Foley. I am a parent
of two students in AISD. I am a child of
AISD, a resident in Austin, Texas. I
have some major concerns about the um
budgets and lack of transparency around
all of the planning happening now um in
conjunction with the um proposed
consolidation and turnaround and school
closure. Uh in 2019, Superintendent
Matias Figura uh came to AISD straight
from ACOM, the contractor that wrote the
facility report used to justify closing
schools. Now he's leading a new round of
closures while AISD pays a company
called Steadystate Impact and TNTP up to
$20 million for supposed turnaround
consulting for a plan that nobody has
seen and is on deadline to be voted for.
Um, parents deserve transparency before
we lose more neighborhood schools and uh
more closures and a diminishing AISD.
and I want to ask the district to
release all the contract.
>> My name is Guawa Gera. I am the parent
of three Austin ISTD students, two of
which attend a 3UA elementary school,
which means for three consecutive years,
their student outcomes on the star test
have not been acceptable and now they
are required by the Texas Education
Agency to go through a turnaround plan.
I also understand that the board is
being monitored by Lonear Governance who
measures minutes as counting towards
student centered outcomes or against.
For some reason, discussions about the
budget do not count towards student
centered outcome minutes even though we
know how much budgets affect student
outcomes. The turnaround plans are the
result of student outcomes. The
turnaround plans are designed to improve
student outcomes. I am asking the board
to clarify tonight with the Lonear
governance monitor who may or may not be
attend attendance. Do board discussions
about the turnaround plans count against
our student centered outcome minutes or
do they count for our student centered
outcome minutes? Please have the Lonear
Governance Monitor clarify this tonight.
Hello, this is Adam Sparks. I just
wanted to bring attention to the fact
that we are three weeks away from a
final vote on turnaround plans and
consolidations in AISD and have not
received any financials for the cost
savings from closing campuses. This is
something that was promised to schools
before October 3rd. It has still not
come out. The district claims that these
numbers are coming out but we are less
than three weeks away and basic
information on the financials of this
plan have not been released. Uh we asked
the board to include any kind of
measurable to ensure that one year, two
years, five years from now, we have
information about whether or not this
plan saved money for the district. As
I've heard trustees say that they would
not vote yes until they had 2019
financials. That information is now
apparently not coming. And so it's
important that we uh measure how this
plan affects the financials of AISD with
real uh measurables in a multi-year
process. Thank you so much.
Thank you to all of our callers and all
of our in-person speakers for your
testimony. Uh trustees, are there any
questions seeking clarification? Trusty
Kintana first.
>> Um I was just going to ask
if the turnaround plan conversations
count toward or not
the
>> It does not. So, the one we are planning
to have um later today um as part of the
superintendent's update would not count.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Count against. Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> No.
>> Trusty Pton,
>> I just had a couple questions for
clarification on some of the um comments
made about the contracts and the um real
estate sales. Could you just comment on
um what 20 million I don't recall a $20
million contract being involved in this.
Can you do you know what that's
referring to and can you speak to that?
Two, can you um just address the
concern about conflict of interest? And
three, can you clarify um on the real
estate? My understanding is that we
often do real estate without
naming a lot of things publicly because
of but anyhow can you comment on whether
that real estate includes any of the
potent the schools that are listed for
potential closure?
>> Uh sure trusty Kaufman. Um uh first off
um this any real any real estate
contracts this is a renewal um not
unlike how we hire attorney or the
professional services we in open up an
RFQ uh or an RFP process invite vendors
or partners to participate we select
them and then as needed throughout the
course of a period of time we will use
them for their services uh this is
precisely what we've done in the past um
and this is effectively a renewal
because the terms in those contracts
have have expired ired. Uh given our
organization, um there are lots of
different ways that we use real estate
um uh partners. Uh some of them have to
do with acquiring of land, some of it
has to do with deposition. It it's just
kind of varied based on on need, which
is why there are different funding
sources used uh or identified in the in
the document itself. Uh regarding a $20
million contract, I'm have no idea what
that is is a reference to. Um I heard
TNTP and City State um identify those
are not contracts of that value. Um
one's a technical partner that we use
for our turnaround plans. Um so yeah, I
I don't have an understanding of that.
Uh regarding, you know, conflicts of of
interest or where I've worked before, um
you know, all of that is available on
our website. It's been disclosed for
many many years. Um I you know, that's
that's been out there. It's out there.
Nothing has changed.
Is I'm not sure if is there anything
else that I
>> I think that covered it. Yeah, thank
you. I appreciate it. I think um the
call for transparency is important, but
I think also refuting kind of
allegations that are unfounded is
important. So, thank you. Yeah. [snorts]
>> Thank you, Trusty Hunter.
>> Thank you. Um, our last caller um had a
question and it's one that I continue to
have um for the financial assessment an
estimation of what we will save by
closing schools and so do we have um an
expected timeline on when we will
receive that?
>> Yeah. So, uh we estimated that in the
initial draft October 3rd 24 million in
the revision that's going to be released
tomorrow. uh we're doing a deeper
breakdown as requested by our community
to go kind of campus by campus. There
obviously assumptions that we have to
use in that modeling regarding kind of
what the staffing allocations are going
to be at the receiving school. Uh and so
you'll see it broken down campus by
campus um you know for for the potential
consolidations that uh we're
considering. It's uh going to be one of
the attachments uh in the deliverables
that are submitted um and released
tomorrow. So will it be I guess I don't
know financially how to say this. Will
it be a cost savings or how much you
would save if you did this or what would
it
>> So so so we are looking at a a savings.
Um one of the things that we're want to
be really clear about is there's um
different assumptions that can be used
to determine you know is there is there
a loss are there a loss is there a loss
in students because of the disruption.
>> Right? We know that that is potential
that that it could happen. And so based
on feedback that we've gotten from our
trustees and from the community, what
we're going to do is kind of just
provide a sensitivity analysis and say
plus 5% plus 5% minus 5% plus 1% to kind
of show the range. Um what we know is
that every school um merger is
different. Uh there are examples in
other school districts where because of
the planning and the thoughtfulness
around the transition, there was a very
low loss in student attrition tied to
the move. Uh back in 2019 when we went
through it, uh it was kind of hard to
tell because the pandemic happens
immediately afterwards and I we keep
forgetting that that happens, but the
vote took place in November of 2019. Um
shortly thereafter, three months after
in fact, the pandemic hit and then
everything kind of just changed. Um so
it is difficult to use our own data from
that period of time uh regarding what
student movement looked like because
lots of families are making decisions
for lots of different reasons and it's
just it was really hard to quantify. So
we decided to provide a range or
sensitivity analysis um based on the
financials so that we could see like
kind of what it the range is likely to
be on on various assumptions. That's
helpful. The other thing that I want to
be really clear about is um offsets or
other costs. We as a district determine
what we spend our dollars on. um there
are resources um allocated as part of
the turnaround plans. Uh we would have
to spend those dollars regardless if we
believe that these are the resources
that need to be deployed to ensure that
we're successful. Um we continue to lump
the two together. I understand why we do
that. Um but if no consolidations and no
savings are made, you're still going to
have the expense. So we we I I am
showing both, but I want to make sure
that it's understood that they're not
necessarily tied together. If one
doesn't happen, the other won't. It we
will still have that expense. Um, I
understand why they're being lumped
together, but that's not how we actually
would operationalize it.
>> Okay. So, for those of us who aren't
great at math, I want to try to restate
to make sure I'm understanding. So, what
you're saying is that
the offsets is the word you used,
they're going to happen no matter what,
whether we have an injection of cash, we
either like have less of a deficit or
the deficit gets deeper. [clears throat]
>> Yeah. So, so, um, when we talk about $24
million, uh, and again, that was a
conservative estimate when we first
released on October 3rd, um, you know,
the the assumption that a year from now,
um, if the $24 million isn't identified
and directly tied to the fund balance
or, you know, kind of offset the fund
balance, then somehow we were not being
transparent because at the same time,
we're electing and deciding to spend
other things, dollar, you know, spend
resources on other things. Um so it's
it's another expense. Uh I call it I use
the word offset because it's been shared
with me as an offset but really it's you
know you know reduction in cost will um
increase your fund balance or increase
your available dollars even though we're
in an already budget deficit but over
here you have additional expenses that
you're going to incur. Um there are
going to be some expenses tied to the
transition plans. For instance, if we
agree to additional transportation
routes to support um a kind of new
campus merger or a different
configuration of a campus, that would be
an additional expense tied to the
consolidations, but the turnaround plans
um are agnostic. Like we're still going
to have to spend those dollars
regardless. Uh so we're we're going to
kind of lay it out in that way, which is
why we've actually broken it out as a
separate attachment in the deliverable
that'll be released tomorrow.
>> Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. Any additional questions,
clarifications? All right. Uh, thank
you. As a reminder, please feel free to
share any comments or questions with the
board by email at trustees
ataustinisd.org.
And before our next item, the board will
go into a brief executive session at
6:25 p.m. Pursuant to Texas Government
Code sections 551.074,
551.072,
551.073,
551.087. 087551.076
551.0821
and 551.071.
When we finish, we will return to open
session to continue our meeting. Thank
you.
Hi, we're returning to the open meeting
at 6:45 p.m. Thank you. Uh, our next
item is under the president's report and
we pause tonight to recognize the
passing of a remark remarkable figure in
Austin ISD history. On Friday, Miss Nan
Clayton passed away in Albuquerque, New
Mexico. Clayton Elementary School, built
and dedicated in 2006, is named in her
honor for her impact on our students and
our district. and I invite Trusty
Compman to offer a brief tribute.
>> Thank you. Uh Nan Clayton dedicated her
life to education and public service,
leaving a lasting legacy that can
inspire generations to come. She was
elected to the Austin ISD school board
in 1978 and served for 14 years. I've
been here three years. 14 years is a
long time. She was the second woman ever
elected as board president. She su
successfully advocated for full day
kindergarten for all children and helped
navigate the district through the
tumultuous era of early efforts to
desegregate Austin schools. She was a
constant courageous voice for fairness
and academic excellence. Nan Clayton was
a longhorn earning bachelor's and
master's degrees from the University of
Texas at Austin. She was a scientist
working as a water quality chemist for
the Texas State Health Department. She
was a teacher in both AISD and Del
Valley ISD. She was a volunteer serving
as president of the Barton Hills
Elementary PTA. She was a South Austin
icon, having lived most of her life
south of the river before moving to
Albuquerque eight years ago for family
and health reasons. She was a spelunker
making history as the first woman to
descend into the inner space caverns in
Georgetown. I first met Nan Clayton in
2005 when I was principal of Becker
Elementary and she invited me to the
monthly meetings of the South Austin
Civic Club. I could sense from the start
her kindness, her strength, her
tenacity, her centering of community,
and her deep commitment to public
schools. All of my subsequent
interactions with her proved my first
impressions to be true and then some. In
2006, Dr. Drew Robinette and I worked
together closely as we opened new
elementary schools across town from each
other. The school board voted to honor
Nan Clayton by naming Dr. Robinette's
new southwest elementary, located just
1.5 miles from my home in Circle C after
her. When I heard the sad news this
weekend, I called Dr. Robinette to
invite her reflections on Nan Clayton.
As you might expect, Drew had a lot to
say. She described how involved Nan was
at the school that bears her name,
calling her the first Clayton Elementary
volunteer. She got a hard hat right away
and walked the campus in 2006, many
times during construction, well before
opening. Then participated in outreach
sessions, picnics, and community
meetings with me with her as a partner
to welcome students, staff, and families
to the new school. and she was an ex
official CAC member for more than a
decade. Drew told me how connected Nan
was to the card Clayton Cardinal
students. She welcomed students each day
on the first day of school. She always
participated in the opening day assembly
and celebration and many others
including the fifth grade ceremony each
year. She was a guest speaker and reader
in classes, getting to know students and
sharing her own story as one of the
earlier women in STEM committed to
learning, igniting curiosity and
creativity. Kindergarten students who
just met her when they started at
Clayton were starruck at first, then
referred to her as the Nan Clayton, but
they soon grew to know and love her as
Mrs. Clayton, a familiar and supportive
leader who was the heartbeat of the
school. Drew shared how Nan was a great
friend and mentor to her and to so many
others because of the value she places
on relationships. She was quick-witted
and a natural connector, supporter, and
confidant. She was easy to talk to and
confide in, to think through challenges,
find new approaches to get things done
and reflect on and follow through with
creative action. Her heart as a
community servant and organizer never
left her, and the curious minds and
questions of school children and their
quality experiences and learning they
deserved only fueled her more. Nan
Clayton was a visionary leader, a
dedicated public servant, a South Austin
landmark, and a true friend to many. As
Drew said, Nan Clayton believed that
great schools make for a great Austin.
Austin ISD and the city of Austin are
better because of Nan Clayton. Her
powerful spirit will live on in the
school that bears her name and in the
city and school district that she loved.
>> Thank you, Trustee Kaufman. And uh our
thoughts are with people who um were
close to Nan Clayton, her family and
friends. Thank you. Um so our next item
up is going to be our committee reports.
and we have posted those committee
reports as an attachment to this item on
our board doc agenda and it includes a
committee report for the policy
committee and the audit committee. Thank
you. And the next item up is the
superintendent report.
>> Thank you, President Boswell. I'd like
to welcome up uh Miss Lkesha Drinks uh
chief of staff um to share an update on
the turnaround plans. We'll also have
Dr. Wilson, assistant superintendent of
secondary school leadership, Dr.
Ammerson, assistant superintendent of
school improvement, and Jennifer Pace,
assistant superintendent of elementary
school leadership. I will provide a
brief presentation and then open it up
to questions. Over to you, Lisha.
>> All right. Good evening, trustees, uh,
President Boswell, um, Superintendent
Siguro. This evening we will share an
overview of our draft strategies for our
district turnaround plans. Um we'll talk
a little bit about how we determine the
strategy that we were planning to
implement as well as a few general
strategies that you'll see across
turnaround plans. Um just for the um
public's knowledge or reminder um our
tabs are posted on our school
improvement website um with a survey
linked so that we are able to receive
feedback um from our communities. So we
are still drafting TAP so there's still
opportunity to provide feedback.
So the first strategy that um that I'm
going to share is the restart strategy.
And so the restart strategy, just as a
reminder, um typically requires pretty
much in every case um a change in campus
staff. So in order to lead a restart
campus, you must be um determined as
highly qualified. Again, we're going to
stick with the language that you'll find
in TAPS um just for consistency sake. So
it does define the the staff at campuses
as needing to be highly qualified. Okay.
I do think that that that's super
important in in following along as to
how we selected the strategy for each
particular school.
Um you'll notice um that our restart
campuses um typically are in modernized
facilities. Um they usually have
according to what we looked at possibly
too many students to reassign. Um and
the previous year's data um does not
reflect steady student growth.
or I'm sorry, it does reflect steady
student growth. So, the first campus
we'll look at is Linder. Um Linder um
there they have a modernized facility
under construction. It is very close to
completion. It is um unreasonable to
stop it at this point. Um the data for
Linder does show that they um have had
significant academic growth um that is
conducive to a restart. So the campus is
um on track um for meeting
accountability. Um we feel like with
some additional supports um some
additional staffing um that they will be
able to to meet accountability.
Um Waldridge Elementary is another um
campus moving into moderniz modernized
facility.
Um their growth actually has been um
accelerated. They actually have had
great growth in domain three. So
remembering domain three is the closing
achievement gaps and so it is a
combination of achievement data versus
student growth data. And so from 2023 to
um Waldridge increased their student
growth points from 30 to 62. So we know
what they're doing is working. We just
have to focus on accelerating what
they're doing and again providing some
additional supports.
Um, same for Pedes Middle School. Paris
Middle School is a a large middle
school, which would would make it um
pretty difficult to um reassign
students. It's also um located in an
area where it's pretty much the only
middle school um in that neighborhood.
And they too are on the path to meeting
uh accountability. So from 2023 to 2025
their domain three score improved from
30 to 73.
Um PCON springs is the um outlier to the
system that we use to determine um which
strategy to implement. Um so we are as
we planned their turnaround plan we are
thinking about probably as the maximum
supports that we're able to provide a
campus. um they have not demonstrated
accelerated or steady growth. Um
however, they do have a modernized um
facility. Um and we do feel like having
by providing them with the additional
support and really making them um a
primary focus, making them one of the
first schools that we that we staff over
the spring um that there is um an
opportunity to meet accountability. But
again, it's this is a campus where we
are still taking feedback from the
community and we we do need to have some
additional conversations before we
finalize their strategy.
So the next strategy that we'll discuss
is reassigning. And so when we made the
determination to reassign students, in
most cases, um the schools where they
are being reassigned or at least the
majority of the students are being
assigned um have acceptable rated
campuses and they're in um relatively
close proximity.
And so we do want to note that some of
the campuses were also being um
considered for a reassignment or a
consolidation just as part of the
consolidation process. And so it came
what we're calling an intersection,
right? So as we're moving on the path of
coming up with the TAP strategy and as
we're working on consolidations, we
ended up
at a cross roads for some campuses
through both processes. and I'll talk
about which campuses those are.
So, Bington Elementary, um 75% of the
students are being reassigned to
Guerrero Thompson. Um elementary.
Guerrero Thompson is currently a B rated
campus. Um for the past three years,
it's gone between A and B rating. Um
Bington was is slated for um
modernization. However, the construction
has not yet started. Um the campus has
not made a significant um amount of
growth within the last three years. Um
and so that was a factor that we
considered because again we we really
considered the amount of growth that
students made um within the last three
years and if the campus was on track to
meeting accountability with some
additional supports.
Um Betachch Middle School um we have 58%
of the students assigned to Cington
Middle School. Cington is rated
currently a C. Um the other students are
reassigned to Mendes and Pedes. Um much
smaller numbers um compared to
Covington.
Um Covington, I'm sorry, Betach has not
had significant um academic growth um to
support a restart strategy from 23 to
2023 to 2025. They improved from a 57 to
a 59.
Next we'll go to Dawson um elementary.
Um Dawson is being assigned at 100% to
um to Galindo. Um Dawson has also not
had a significant amount of accelerated
growth and also the size of their uh
resides population um
limits their overall number of students.
So currently there are around 150
students for the entire campus and if
you think about spreading that out um
you have very few students testing and
that's something that you'll also see
with Oak Springs. And so when you have
such a small group testing um the weight
of each student is is very heavy and it
makes navigating our accountability
system um challenging.
So, I
spoke um a little bit about Oak Springs
when I talked about the size of the
campus. So, Oak Springs is another
another one of our um small campuses. Um
right now we are our plans have them
being reassigned um to Blackshere as
100% of the students. Um I do want to
say we've not yet had the community
meetings um with the Blackshere
community. So, this is definitely um
very drafty, I'm going to say, because
we we do still need to get um more input
um from Oak Springs and also from um
from the Black Shear communities.
Next, we have Martin. Again, I think
you'll notice a pattern with some of
with most of the schools that we are
reassigning, and it's that they have
very small um numbers of of students
attending. So Martin's a little bit
different because their resides area
would actually
give us more substantial numbers, but
not all of those students are electing
to attend. Um so again, small numbers
testing
creates a a very heavy weight um on the
students that we do have. And so we have
Martin being reassigned with 46% to
Keeling,
um 28% to Marshall, and 26% to Lively.
And so you'll notice in our strategies
that we talk about, uh strategic
staffing, um which includes additional
staffing. So, I do think it's important
to put in the space um that we recognize
that we will need to provide these
supports not just to the campuses that
are receiving the turnaround plans, but
for campuses that are supporting any of
these students currently assigned to
campuses requiring a turnaround plan.
Um, next we have Sanchez. um their
student growth too has been somewhat
stagnant. In uh 2023 um their domain 3
score was a 54 and in 2025 um a 58. Um
we have 53% of the students being
assigned to Allison. Um Allison
currently has um three Ds. So that is a
one UA rating. And so DA uh Allison is a
campus that is receiving students that
will have um more substantial support um
than some of our other campuses
receiving students. So I think it's
important to say if you're sending
students to campuses that are meeting
accountability um it is assumed that
those campuses have systems and supports
to that allow their students to grow. um
in turn the campus meets accountability.
And so we wouldn't want to go into those
campuses and really make disruptions. We
want to be able to support what it is
that they're already doing so that they
can support additional students.
And last we have Win Monasuri. And so
when is is one of the campuses that as
we were looking at um at that um their
attendance zone and then that area of
Austin, we had additional seats. We have
more seats there than we had students.
So there was already um we'd already
identified the need to reduce seats in
that area, not necessarily win, but in
the area, right? So then when we start
to develop the turnaround plan and we we
reached out to the WIN community, we had
a number of engagement meetings. One
thing that we did learn from the wind
community is that they have a desire to
uh to keep the monastery program. And so
if we were to restart WIN, um we would
not have been able to restart it with
the monastery program. I'm not say we
couldn't. It would be very challenging
because we would have needed to turn the
staff over and find new teachers that
are bilingual and monastery certified
and staffing has provided to be um a
great challenge to Monasuri and so we
don't have confidence that we that we
would be able to restart it with the
appropriate staff. Um for Wedane we have
them being reassigned to um to
Rodriguez. [clears throat]
um 69% students that will be assigned
there. Um while Rodriguez currently um
has a 69, they have historically had
higher student achievement in 2024 they
actually were a B-rated campus. And so
what we're going to work with Rodriguez
on actually currently working with them
on is just having more consistency um in
their system and their supports.
And then last we have our two UA
campuses. And so with these campuses we
are not um
implementing such extreme strategies. Um
we are going with the school improvement
model. And so in those cases it really
is just supporting uh the campus with
wraparound services. Again in some cases
additional staff um helping them to tier
teachers for support.
And so upcoming dates as we continue to
develop the tap is on November 20th. We
will have the tap public hearing. Um the
you all will vote on the taps um also on
the 20th and then November 21st is our
deadline to submit the board approved
taps to uh to tea.
>> Thank you.
>> All right.
>> Thank you for all of that. Um there is a
lot in this and this is profoundly
important stuff. Um we are going to
because this does not count as student
outcome minutes as we clarified early.
Um and yet it is extremely important um
really to the the health and support of
our district. We are going to try to
keep our comments to three minutes each
comments and questions and we hope any
questions will also be very very tight.
we need to really try to make this work
and we will submit what we can't by um
by email and then I think it might be
helpful to and I'll talk with um you
about this superintendent Sigura to
maybe have a public meeting about this
as well where we present these to the
public and more people can hear since
our time is limited here today um so I
know we're presenting them on campuses
but this matters to the whole district
so um let's just go down the list uh
trusty Foster are you ready if not we
can go to Trusty Hunter
U I'll I'll
expect followup instead of asking for uh
response now but I like to know that if
or I'd like to know if Monasuri were to
continue what would be the substantive
differences that you know sort of
defined it or made the difference. Um
but that can be followed up upon in
writing.
>> Thank you Trusty Hunter. Thank you for
the presentation. Um I want to register
some concerns and um would really like
to know that we have students moving
from schools that are already UA to
another UA schools. So speaking about
Bington and then when students are um
being split between Andrews Pon Springs
and um Hart also UA schools if you could
very quickly kind of tell me what sort
of supports and plans we have that will
I mean stop the perpetuation of another
UA.
>> My time is running.
>> Yeah, I I'll speak generally to to both
levels. Um right now our campuses are
heavily engaged in learning lab work
through TNTP. We have lighthouse models
at the secondary level. Marshall is a
lighthouse model and then we have seven
other middle school campuses that are
included within that learning lab model.
You see schools like Keeling and Lively
that you normally
>> just about the elementaryaries.
>> Oh okay.
>> The elementaryaries. Yes.
>> So Bington and when
>> Yes. And and what um Dr. Wilson was
saying also applies to elementary
schools. We are implementing the
lighthouse program and that's to provide
additional um leadership coaching,
teacher coaching, monthly professional
learning um with hands-on application,
additional progress monitoring and
increased instructional rounds.
especially in the case really in both
schools having really intentional
transition plans for students moving out
of their program into a new program for
when especially they're going from one
program type to a traditional type. So
just having a strong support plan in
place for that transition and then for
Bington students going into especially
Guerrero Thompson um having a
significant group uh coming in with
learning gaps and having an accelerated
plan for them.
>> Thank you so much. I hate to um cut you
off but you kind of lead us to the next
point. Um those students leaving Bington
going to Waldridge and GT. A lot of uh
my concern is about not having that life
skills program there. And so I know that
that is supposed to happen. Uh Dr. Sher
Lee I think spoke to that a little bit
previously. So I would expect that the
comm the communication to the community
would be very clear so that parents
understand what is going to happen with
their children's services. And finally
um I saw that uh for Pon Springs the
emerging bilingual sped supports again
overcommunication with parents about how
their children are going to continue to
receive those services. And lastly,
domain 2A, the growth goals of literacy
um at Oak Springs. A little bit of
concern there, but again, um if we could
have monitoring and with the board
getting back to us about like so we have
these plans and once they're implemented
like how they are actually working. So I
appreciate that. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Trusty Singh.
>> Okay, I've got three questions. One is I
noticed summer school was listed in some
of these, but I really would love to
have more information on that and like
how are we making sure that the kids um
are coming together, especially on these
consolidated campuses um to get to know
each other because we all know that um
this is this is creating mental health
disruptions for students, right? And how
that impacts their learning. So, I just
I was really hoping to see more detail
on what, if anything, we are doing this
summer before um school starts next fall
to bring communities together to relieve
some of that anxiety so that they do
show up ready to learn. Um I really
really hope that is in our programs um
and and our taps [snorts] um and and
what KPIs we're using to to determine
success for that. So, that's one. Um the
second one is I would love to understand
the the key performance indicators. How
how do we know we are successful for
family engagement? Again, this is a big
time of transition for so many of our
families. They don't a lot of them don't
understand what's going on. I want to
know, superintendent, is there a plan to
ensure every single parent gets some
kind of human contact with their child's
school to understand where their kid is
academically with math and reading and
create that relationship because that is
critical. Um I I saw I saw me mentions
of engagement, but I wouldn't like to
see what we're going to be doing
differently, which to me is like just
deeper um follow through with individual
parents. And then finally, uh, child
study teams. You know, how that's not
something we talk a whole lot about
here. And honestly, I'm not an expert in
it, but from what I know, this is the
when I've talked to at least one
principal who was very successful, a
very successful Title One school, she
said that that was like a very key piece
of it is they don't let any kids fall
through the cracks. And so I really want
to understand um superintendent whether
it's in the TAP plan or not um what is
the district doing to ensure that kids
are not falling through the cracks um
with those child study teams and how do
we how how are you as a superintendent
ensuring um fidelity with with our
model. That is that those are my three
things. So thank you so much.
Um, Trusty Gonzalez,
>> I have um questions that related to some
of the questions have already been posed
that I can submit in more detail through
writing. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Um, I have a list of
questions that I'm going to run through
and I'll send them by email as well. Um,
I have asked and uh would still like to
see statewide data about A throughF
distributions at campuses across the
state with similar demographics and
other variables like mobility, special
education percentages, emergent
bilingual status, economic need. I
really want to understand if we are
creating schools that have track records
of being successful in other places and
how big a hill we're setting up for
ourselves to climb. I really want to
understand to what degree students at
schools in similar situations are seeing
success in our state's accountability
system knowing that our standardized
tests also do a good job of measuring
what kids bring to school with them and
how well we're providing those other
supports. Um, I am deeply concerned
about our F2D schools and our FTOC
schools, especially our FTD schools, and
really want to know why we believe that
will work and and what's different about
those plans. Um, I'd like to know um
what root cause analysis has been done
to understand the reasons that our
schools are in this situation. I'd like
to know how TNTP was chosen, who else
was considered, and how much we will be
paying if this is approved. Um, family
engagement is one of the levers that TEA
includes. I'd like to know if that's
part of any of these plans. I saw a lot
about wraparound services and um,
support for chronic absenteeism. Didn't
see a whole lot of that. Um, and I know
that TEA has some really solid plans for
that. So, would really like to
understand that, especially at our
elementary schools, but also at our
other secondary schools. Um there are
very high numbers of students receiving
special education services at some
campuses and I'd like more detail on how
we're accounting for that. Um we know
that a lot of these are in areas with a
lot of charter schools that um tend to
have much lower percentages that
concentrates that need on our campuses
and I really want to know how we're
addressing that um to help our students
be successful and help our schools um
break this accountability chain. Um
there's a whole lot of need among
students at many of these campuses. I
saw some plans to address that, but I'd
like more detail on how we're going to
address chronic absenteeism. Um, what
we're doing about mobility um to help
offer supports. We had a tool at one
point that we paid for that reduced
mobility. Are we planning to wrap that
into it so we can help families find
apartments? Our parent support
specialist used it and it demonstrated
success. Uh would like to know if we've
considered an extended school year at
any of our schools. Would like to know
what expertise beyond Austin ISD are we
leaning into for guidance. There are a
lot of people in our community eager to
do that. I think we need to talk about
that. Um Dobby Web and Burn, I'd like to
know what we know about how it's working
or how it's not working and how that's
reflected in these plans. Um what are
our options after taps begin if we're
not seeing progress to get an acceptable
rating? Um I'd like to know what our
plan is for really staffing this. We had
a short shortage of staff even to staff
those three that counted as highly
qualified under TEA's definition. I
don't know what our plan is for that,
but I'd like to understand that. And
then the two UA schools, how are these
different from the two UA tips from last
time? And if it didn't work to prevent
our three UA last time, what are we
doing differently to be sure we are?
Thank you.
>> Okay. Um, so for Pan Springs Linder
Woolridge Bedetas,
what happens if any of those schools
get an F in 2026 and an F label in 2027?
So, so for 2425 and then 2526,
correct?
>> So, if PCON springs lender
are put out as
>> um are labeled with a F by TEA
in 2026
and 2027,
what happens next?
Well, I mean, so they're 3UA right now.
Um, if they continue on this year, get
an F. Um, then that would be their four
UA. Um, if they continue on and get
their fifth UA, then state intervention
could include installation of a board of
managers or closure of the school.
>> Okay.
And then how does this plan
prevent that from happening?
So
we're developing
this comprehensive plan, all the
turnaround plans with resources deployed
based on we know about these schools.
You know, we are investing and using
strategies to pull these schools out and
support them so they break the
accountability chains. Many of them, as
Lisha said, have already demonstrated
growth in the right direction or are
close to either getting a pause and we
expect many of them will get that pause
if not break the chain. Nothing is
guaranteed
>> like for what what does that mean a
pause? So if there's a pause, so so in
the 23 24 25 accountability when we have
many many schools that have 59s, many I
think there's nine and then several that
are 58s and 57s. Um and uh you know
there if they were to receive a D then
that would pause the accountability
chain um and that uh would that would
not count as an additional UA. So let's
use Pettis for example. Predes I believe
was already a 59. Um based on what we've
seen at the campus already, we believe
we're very confident they'll break
they'll pause the accountability chain
at a minimum if not break it this year.
But let's assume they get a D, then the
25 26 accountability would not be a
fourth UA. It would be maintain a third
UA with the D. So then 26 27 if they
received enough at that point or if they
broke the accountability chain which is
what my expectation would be then and
they would never have essentially gotten
their their fourth or fifth. Um so
there's lots of different combinations
but a D pauses C breaks.
>> Okay, that'd be three minutes just in
case you want to know.
>> All right, and then I I will send the
rest of my questions and hopefully
there's a place where the public can see
the answers to them. Thank you.
>> I'd love to have these questions posted
on our accountability on our school
improvement page, please. Thank you.
>> So, the question all the questions that
were getting off the DIS or the ones
that are receiving Okay.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> I'm gonna have to
All my questions have been asked and
answered if I come up with anything
else.
>> Thank you, Trusty Kintana.
Um, I already
>> Oh, okay. Perfect. Thank you.
>> Okay. Um, I already sent in mine to
y'all, but just very quickly, I just
wanted to know about our bond dollars,
about um the campuses that are closing
and where those will go. Um, how the TAP
dollars will follow students whose
campuses are closing and they're being
reassigned.
um how we're going to staff the um
restarts um what happens to the staff at
the campus that receives the majority of
the students in the TAP. Um and then how
we plan to recruit staff. Actually, I
just said that. Okay, good. Um and then
um
yeah, that's basically it. So, I already
sent those in, but I just wanted to make
sure I said that publicly. Thank you.
>> Thank you. And Trusty Hunter has a
question on behalf of Dr. Kaufman. Uh
Trusty Kaufman went to uh a fled
anniversary at Pereas where he was
principal.
>> Okay. Um one question he has is what are
the lessons learned learned from the
last three years of turnaround and
school improvement plans particularly
around support and implementation?
Did you I can I can provide a brief
response brief response. Um, one of the
things is I would say is that you have
to have a a thoughtful plan that we know
we can execute with the resources we
have. Uh, the turnaround plans for Adobe
Burn and Web based on a timeline
established by the state, they were very
very tight. Um, and when it came to the
hiring timeline that we go through as an
organization, it was late into the
spring semester. So because of where we
are now and because of what we're going
through with consolidations, I do
believe we'll have ample time to build
out the staff, ensure the resour
resources are deployed so that we start
this the school year successfully. So I
I do believe that what we learned is
time matters. Having time to plan and
implement, prepare so that we're we're
ready to go is critically important. Um
that's one big difference this time
around.
>> Um another difference is having data
points to monitor centrally. Um this is
one of this is probably the first year
in quite some time that we have
dashboards that we could see um at the
campus level as well as the district
level how students are progressing
throughout the year. um having three
data points a year makes it hard for us
to respond and provide um campus with
additional support because if you don't
know until the end of the year the I
mean the ship has sailed for that year
so to speak and the students have
accumulated greater gaps right and so we
are monitoring data on a very regular
basis coaching principles through
looking at their data bringing data into
senior leadership so that we can deploy
um resources in a more timely manner um
I will say a lot of it is having more
having solid systems in place that we
have not necessarily had over over the
last few years.
>> Thank you so
much.
>> Thank you very much. Um it's 7:21. We
are within our 30 minutes. Does anyone
have additional questions? Do we feel
like we have asked and answered?
Okay. I think um thank you for this. I
think uh this is an immense deal and uh
really appreciate your work, our
colleagues questions and the ability to
really understand um any one of these
fails. I know the pressure is huge and
any one of these is not successful for
our students and that is a real risk to
our whole district. So thank you for
this and I know you're doing hard work.
Thank you.
I think we're ready for you. Yeah.
>> I'd like to welcome up Joshua Joshua
John to um I believe provide the
intruder detection um presentation and
update to the board of trustees.
>> Thank you superintendent.
>> Had a lot of board meetings over the
past couple of days. Will someone come?
All
right. Good evening, board of trustees.
In the months of September and October
2025, uh there were 21 schools audited
by TEA. Eight schools had one or more
findings requiring corrective action. Uh
TEA is required to audit 75% of Austin
ICD schools during the 2526 school year.
Currently, Austin ISD is at 17.9% of
campuses audited so far this school
year. In each of the past two school
years, TEA has audited 100% of Austin
ISD schools for intr intruder detection
audits.
That is it.
>> Thank you very much. Uh are there any
questions or clarifications about this
update?
Right. Thank you very much.
Um all right, Superintendent, can you
please in introduce our next item?
>> Yes, President Boswell, I'd like to
welcome up Katrina McGomery, uh chief
financial officer, to provide a brief
update.
regarding our budget.
>> Hello um President Boswell and trustees.
So we're going to provide a brief update
today on our budget. So for FY2425
you see a overview and what we wanted to
show with this slide is that all of the
things that transpired for FY2425
um we were able we're projecting that
from our unodudited financial statements
that will land at a $79 million deficit.
There were points in the year where we
had projected higher, but we did a lot
of great work in reducing our expenses
as well as making reductions throughout
the year.
For FY226,
this slide here is just an update or a
context. And I'm going to point out a
couple points. Um, our expenditure, our
operating budget is $992 million. Our
recapture is 700, if estimated at $715
million.
um cash management. We have some tax
collections. We'll be re we'll start
receiving those in mid November. Um and
then over the next few weeks, we're
going to continue to redefine our budget
strategies. And then at the end on
tomorrow is October snapshot where we
can start doing additional estimates on
on our enrollment and ADA.
The fund ba ba um fund balance policy
was approved by the board um at in June
of last year for us to have a 2425 year
1 year 2 year 3 at 15% and then the the
final year 2728 to be at 20%. Um we're
estimating again at the end of June of
that we'll be above the 15%.
So this document is our is going to show
our amendment. The second column is our
unodudited [clears throat] financial
statements which show if you see the net
change it gets us at $79 million um
where we had been projecting 11090 where
we're going down um 2526 the adopted
budget we ended at um the adjusted net
change was at 19.75 million that was
going to leave us at a 15% fund balance
and then in September of 2526 you can
see our revenue decrease because our tax
collections have decreased increased.
Um, our recapture number has also gone
down, but in total, the adjusted net
change will get us at 17.54
with the uh additional reductions that
we have to make of $92.5 million. So, as
of this amendment, it'll show as long as
we keep to this right hand column, that
will show that we'll have a fund balance
at the end of the year of 17.48%.
The general fund expenditure um spend,
we want to give you an update quarterly.
So quarterly um for 2526 is in the
middle. Um our operating expenditures
are $216 million. Um for the first
quarter of our budget, that means our
spend should have been at $251 million.
So we're under our budget by $35
million. Then to the far right, we also
want to show you where we were this same
time last year. It was the exact same
thing. We were at $35 million under
budget. What we have to do when we look
at these numbers is even though these
look favorably, we have to make sure
that we're continuously reducing our
expenses, managing our cash, and not
continuing to give any additional funds
over our budget.
So, cash management
agenda 14.2. So, we've been monitoring
our cash and as of November 30th, we
will not be in the place to make
payroll. So, what we are presenting here
today is for us to have a loan for and
it's called a tax and revenue
anticipation note. Um, it's used to
finance cash flow deficits in a school
district's fiscal year um in
anticipation of receiving tax and other
revenues in the last in the fiscal year.
So what happens is when we end June we
have our fund balance which is equates
to our savings account and we live off
of that for July, August, September,
October and in November and then when we
in November we start getting tax
collections but they will be slow and so
there will be a period of time from
November the last November 30th through
the first week of December 5th that cash
will be low to non-existent. So, our
amount that we're um asking the board to
approve is $19 million. This is the
minimal amount. We've been very
strategic at monitoring cash, monitoring
our accounts payable. This is the
minimal amount that we can borrow. I
will tell you that our financial
advisors have asked us or suggested that
we borrow more, but because of the rates
and the fees, we're going to to borrow
the least amount that we need to get us
through the first week of December. The
interest rate is 4.67. 67% and the
repayment date is January 13, 2026.
We're also doing this because we want to
borrow the money at the as the least
amount of time as possible so that we
don't have to incur more than um
additional fees.
This is the 2425 cash flow trend and it
still shows the same thing like in
November of 2024 our cash cash starts to
really get pretty close but in prior
years we've been able to manage that.
What I wanted to be clear is we do not
or did not want to get to November and
say oh we're here. So what this is is a
plan that is done in advance so that we
can get ourselves through November.
So I want to talk about this. This is
our scale. And so one of the things when
I talked to my team yesterday and today
I felt like we're not it it the urgency
might not be there for everyone to
understand where we need to be. And so
we I talked about the scale and Adriana
and the team were like, I don't
understand what you're saying, but this
is the best way we can show the picture
right now because of our fund balance
and our cash balance is low. We're
tipped and these are all the other
things that we're doing that are giving
us all of these great programmings,
compensation, planning periods, 116
campuses, all of these things. But then
these things have are overwhelming us.
And so I want to make sure that we all
walk away here today understanding the
urgency of where we are as a district.
These next few slides I won't really go
over Matias. So um we'll stop there.
I'm available for questions.
>> Thank you. Uh any questions?
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Trusty Hunter.
>> [clears throat]
>> We can do the timer. Okay. Um
I guess I wanted some clarity because
the slides were really I I guess
are you saying we don't have any money
as of November 30th? We will not we will
not have enough to make payroll. And
what you are asking us to do right now
is to approve a loan.
>> Yes.
>> So that we can do
>> so that we can make our November 30th
payroll.
>> So that we can pay the people who are
doing the work every day.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Okay.
And you said in 24 we came close
>> 2425
at the end of the um period [snorts] we
ended up with $50 million.
And so when I look at the projections
and I've been looking at them, we've
been meeting every single week. I am
projecting that we'll get to the $19
million and we still have cash coming
in. But what I do not and will not do is
for us for me to get to November and
say, "Okay, this is where we are." So
this is we're still going to be working
to draw down grants and save money and
watch cash, but I we cannot get to the
place where we don't know that we can
cover the November 30th payroll. So,
we're going to borrow money.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> And there's interest on that money.
>> Yes.
>> There's a payday loan.
>> Okay, I'm good.
>> Trusty Singh and then Trusty Kintana.
>> Um, I just wanted to hear how we got to
this point a little bit more.
>> Yeah, I mean it's it's been an
amalgamation of decisions and
indecisions over the last two years. Um
you know I think the thing that uh we've
talked about is how important fund
balance is. I've been saying that since
the moment I came on the dis. We've
making difficult decisions to try to
short fund balance reduce our costs over
and over again. And um you know this
past year we adopted a deficit a deficit
budget which pushed down our available
fund balance. And then what happens is
you have a statewide tax rate election
for homesteads and all of the um kind of
revenue slows down. So in a typical
year, you know, we would the f the cash
comes in right as we get to that line.
Uh as you probably know, our property
values, the way that we pay our tax
assessor, all that's delayed because of
where we are right now with the
statewide elections. So this is how
sensitive it is. We always talked about
that dip that those two or three weeks
delay like create this. It's really like
a week and a half that this is occurring
in our entire fiscal year. Um if it was
a normal year, don't know it would
exactly be like this. Uh but the the
pressure from the election coupled with
the slow um kind of revenue stream
coming in from property taxes has
created this um kind of risk that we're
managing. Go ahead. with this um you
know debt service.
>> Yes, Trusty Singh. And I also want to
add from 2017 to 2018 every single year
other than 2223 we've passed a deficit
budget and 2223 we didn't do that
because of ESER and so it's just
continuing to borrow. We've just been
borrowing from ourselves right because
we weren't we weren't living within our
means the whole time.
>> No, I appreciate that. So just but
specifically for this because when we
approved the budget there was no talk
that we you know I I'm surprised I'll be
honest. I'm just surprised because this
is not something that we had budgeted
for. So and and I know that we've been
very fiscally responsible. So I'm not
casting espersions on that. I know we've
been making a lot of cuts and um you've
been doing a great job, Miss Montgomery,
as well in your role. But is it because
of a delay in funds that are coming in
from the state? Like help me.
>> So that's one of the bigger drivers.
That's one of the is like our fault or
>> we're talking about we're talking about
cash flow, not we're talking about cash
flow, not
>> total expenses and revenue like at the
end of the year, the end of the fiscal
year, you know, the budget is the budget
that'll hold. It's cash flow. We talk
about cash flow all the time and how
important it is. And as Katrina said, we
are we have to revenue doesn't come till
November. And so we are paying out every
single month. And and one of the things
that's happened this year in particular
because of the homestead exemption laws,
right? So remember the homestead
exemption law that's going to be passed
probably most likely. Well, every single
property owner is not going to pay until
that occurs, right? I mean, property uh
bills aren't going out in the way they
did previously. that that all those
things make it to where property taxes
aren't being paid, revenue is not being
sent to us in the same time line that it
had in previous years. Now, those weeks
matter, right? We always talked about
November, November, November. And
unfortunately, that slight delay given
our monthly payroll kind of created this
this gap and in cash flow. That's really
what it is. I think that's really
important to make very very clear to the
public that that's the reason and it's
not because of overspending.
>> We're Katrina just said that we're
spending 20 $25 million less this fiscal
year based on budget.
>> Like that's the headline people.
>> Okay. Like please know that we we just
got our high our superior first rating.
>> Yeah.
>> We adopted a responsible budget. We've
made cuts. This is not due to
overspending. This is due to a delay in
tax um
>> the biggest driver
>> revenue due to new homestead laws.
>> Yeah. So I think
>> pending the election
>> pending election. So
>> the election. Yeah.
>> So there's a slide um the one that says
as of September 30th 2025 fiscal year
and it says you know based on our burn
rate per month you're 35.26 million
under budget. Right? But cash is what
matters. that's that's that's not the
same thing. Um and and that's what we're
having to manage in this moment given
the way tax revenue is coming in based
on the change at the state level.
>> Thank you. Trusty Kintana,
>> I think all my questions have been asked
and answered. Thank you.
>> Okay. Anyone else?
>> Okay. I want to thank you for bringing
this to us. I know this can't have been
an easy thing for you to know that you
have to bring and to get to a place and
thank you for being ahead of it. It's a
horrible position to be in, but it's
better to be in it now than to wait till
the crisis had come. So, I really
appreciate that. Um, I would like to ask
the administration to consider, I know
we knew we were right at that edge with
reducing our fund balance and changing
that policy. I would love for uh the
administration to consider a proposed
change on that. And do we need to be at
16%, do we need to rethink that 15%. Is
it is it just too close to the edge? um
for our budgets going forward. So I
would welcome a recommendation on that
from the administration and the policy
committee. Um thank you and and really
appreciate it and I think you know we
are not the only district in this
situation. We're not the only Central
Texas district in this situation and I
think this is the reality in our state.
Rice University study in the fall in the
spring said 73% of districts were not
receiving enough um state funding was
not adequate to meet their needs and uh
I know we're in a really really hard
situation. Um so thank you.
All right. Um that is solemn and hard.
Yeah. Um, at the same time, we're trying
to
pay for all the things we know our
students need to be successful. And I
think it's really important to
understand that we know how to do it.
Our our staff know exactly what to do
when we do have the funds. We're showing
that it works. So, thank you. Um, our
next item up is
an update about Mendes and Third Future
with our 1882 agreement. I see you here.
Thank you for being here with us. Uh, as
part of that agreement, we've asked our
partner to provide a quarterly update
and Mr. Ratic and principal Miranda have
a recorded presentation that's included
in board docs tonight and uh they have a
presentation with backup data. Thank you
both for being here.
Uh and uh Superintendent Sigura
welcome
>> I'd like to welcome up uh Mr. Zach
Kratic and principal Elizabeth Midanda.
Uh they are here from Third Future to
answer any questions the board of
trustees may have. Um, thank you for the
presentation earlier.
>> Thank you, trustees. Are there any
questions for clarification?
>> Trusty S.
>> Just super quick, I had submitted some
questions that are on board docs and
there I think there's some blanks in
there, but I would just appreciate um
getting answers to those questions.
These these are just basically the
criteria that we had put that are in our
contract and I just wanted the public to
have a real clear picture of um how
Third Future has performed on each of
the different items in a real simple
format. You guys have given us a lot of
good information. Okay. I just want it
all consolidated in one place so that we
can just see that.
>> I'll work with Josh to make sure that
you get it or if we haven't provided it
already. Um if not I apologize.
>> No, that's the two questions that we had
was the last three years of NWA data.
the district summary report and then the
percentage of our AOT. Our data analysis
person will return from vacation
tomorrow. I will have that for you next
week.
>> Thank you. Appreciate that.
>> Thank you very much. Anything else?
Trusty Whitley.
>> Yeah. Um I wanted to know how many um
students do you have in algebra 1
enrolled in algebra 1 at Mendes this
year?
>> We don't zero students in algebra 1 this
year, ma'am. In eighth grade.
>> Okay.
>> What about last year? We have not
offered algebra 1 at Mendes since we've
taken over operations in 2022.
>> Okay. Um Mr. Ser, do we have any middle
schools in Austin ISD that do not offer
algebra 1?
>> I
>> I'm not aware of one that doesn't offer
it. I'd have to I we offer it at all of
the schools, but I can't. Dr. Wilson, is
there anything you'd want to add to
that?
>> It's all of them. Yes,
>> all of our schools. Okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any additional questions?
>> Trusty Gonzalez.
>> Hi, thank you. I just had one small
clarification question. I did notice
that in the PowerPoint that you shared
the uh enrollment information for sixth
grade and seventh grade was exactly the
same, like exactly the same gender
breakdown, racial breakdown. I didn't
know if that was accidental, like just
the name of the grade level didn't
change, or if they actually are in fact
exactly the same enrollment numbers.
It's
>> highly unlikely, but do you know about
that?
Right. So, so it was probably deemed
accidental. I can give you the
enrollment numbers for sixth and seventh
grade.
>> You don't have to give it to me right
now. I just I would like to know what
the current enrollment is, but I just
didn't know if that was in reality just
coincidental or if it was a mistake.
>> No, sir. It was definitely overlooked.
>> Thank you. I appreciate and I also will
say um
>> on an additional note, very fast, I did
appreciate the inclusion of the pictures
and the visuals and the artifacts. Um
those are all very important. I did get
to see the back to school night, the
virtual one that you held at the
beginning of this year and so um I was
appreciative that all the parents were
wellreceived. It was, you know, a lovely
gathering and very informative. So,
thank you for sharing.
>> They just finished up a Halloween
celebration with over 200 fans 7 p.m.
So, just about an hour ago.
>> Yeah. A lot of fun.
>> Sorry you missed it.
>> I know. It's [laughter] okay.
Uh anything else?
>> This is way more fun than a Halloween
party, right?
>> I agree. Absolutely. [laughter]
Trusty saying absolutely.
>> You could have come to our meeting in
questions. [laughter]
Um, anything else?
Okay. Thank you very much. I appreciate
it.
>> Um, okay. We will now move to the
consent agenda at our October 10th board
information session. Uh, the approval of
linear algebra innovative course was
previewed as an item to be voted on at
today's meeting. Uh the administration
has removed this item from today's
agenda ahead of the meeting. We will
still be offering that course. Uh but
the state board of education is expected
to review the rules regarding innovative
courses at its November meeting. And as
a result of that, the innovative course
application process has been cause uh
paused and the Texas Education Agency
has extended the expiration date for
courses requiring renewal this year to
the 2627 school year. So that of course
will still be uh provided with no need
for a vote. Uh so are there any consent
items anyone would like to pull for a
separate vote?
All right. Um Secretary Gonzalez, do I
have a motion to approve the consent
agenda?
>> Uh yes. I move to approve item 8.1, item
9.1, item 10.1, 10.2, 2, item 11.1
through 11.5, item 12.1 and item 13.1
through 13.1 and 13.2.
>> Thank you. Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Trustees, any discussion on
these items?
>> Just um quick discussion on the mental
health um contract. I just wanted to
thank the administration for following
through with um the promise we made to
voters with using Prop A funds to put I
think it is I can't remember the exact
amount um maybe somebody does for the
for the contract for mental health.
>> I don't want to misspeak. It's in the
hundreds of thousands of
>> I think it's 500,000.
>> I think it was say four or six.
>> Yeah. $500,000. And this is you and I
specifically asked is this going to
supplement or supplant? and it is going
to supplement um our mental health
services. So that is an increase in
services for our students and really
truly appreciate um you're following
through with that that commitment.
>> Thank you. And I have one question about
that one. Is that intended to be a
recurring expense year overyear? Uh
since that was what we asked you we
asked for it in the um
the TR.
>> Uh well the expense won't be the same.
the the allocation may change um because
it's based on services this existing
contract I guess I mean can I get
familiar I don't Dr. Maxel, if you want
to come up. Um,
long term the revenue is year-over-year,
right? I can't say what it'll we'll
spend the dollars on in six years, eight
years, but so the intent is to have the
investment move forward.
>> The intent is to continue investing in
mental health services with the money
that our community approved.
>> Correct. Okay, that's that's really my
question. Okay.
>> Yeah, I know budgets can change a lot of
thing, but that is the intent.
>> Yeah. And contracts can change as well.
>> Thank you very much. I appreciate that.
Thank you, Dr. Maxwell. Okay. Any uh
further questions or comments before we
move on to a vote? All right. Having a
motion by Secretary Gonzalez and a
second by Trustee Kintana to approve
consent agenda agenda items 8.1, 9.1,
10.1, and 10.2, 11.1 through 11.5, 12.1,
13.1, and 13.2.
All in favor, please raise your right
hand. And the motion passes unanimously.
Thank you.
Um, and we have no items that have been
pulled.
Um,
okay. Now we will move to items for
separate votes. Secretary Gonzalez, do
we have a motion to approve item 14.1?
>> Yes. I motion to approve I move to
approve item 14.1 considering possible
action on LSG quarterly and yearly
evaluation.
>> Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Um, so I believe we have
Ashley Paws with us via Zoom, our Lonear
governance coach. Um,
and uh, this is
many quarters in now and uh, we've se
seen some shifts and I would love to
have Ashley here. Um, hello Ashley, I
see you now.
um would love to have the chance to go
through this together uh just to help
understand kind of what we're looking at
how that's happened and then there's an
annual evaluation and I know that's part
of our commitment under lonear
governance as well and that's something
that you'll see reflected on the
self-evaluation. So Ashley I would love
for you to um kind of fill our community
in on on where we are, what this is and
what's different this time and then we
can ask some questions. Does that work
for you?
Yeah, absolutely.
>> And I think this is the first time we've
seen the annual evaluation and I think
it would be really helpful for our
community to hear about that as well
because that's new in this form.
>> Yes, absolutely. Um so, uh let's start
actually with the annual self-evaluation
or so it's not an annual
self-evaluation. It's the same
self-evaluation. It's uh simply just an
annual review. So um what what we've
done is we've provided the board with um
all of the data from your uh past 12
months of implementation uh so that you
can see the progress that you have made
um in in implementing um these effective
governance practices um o over the last
12 months. So um what this includes is
um 12 months of your um your time use.
It includes 12 months of all of the
things that you have uh accomplished
during that time. Um so all of those
implementation steps um as you're doing
your self-evaluations those are the
conversations that uh that you're having
like have we checked this box u and one
of the um the notes that I have included
uh in this self-evaluation is that um
you know we often it's easy to get lost
um for the conversation to get lost on
um you know [clears throat] checking
boxes because that's literally what
we're doing um while that
self-evaluation is being conducted. Ed,
but every single one of those boxes is
actually um a move toward uh creating
the conditions for student outcomes to
improve. Um you know, how how you are
evaluating your superintendent, how you
are setting goals, how you are
monitoring your goals, how uh you're
spending your time during your board
meetings, how you're engaging with the
community. um you know, how how you are
aligning your budget, how you're
aligning your policy, and all of um all
of the things that you do within the
district, how you are coming closer and
closer into alignment um so that you can
uh really begin to um to do uh great and
amazing things and build on the uh great
and amazing things that you're already
doing uh in service of students. And so
that really is the purpose of this 12
month uh just this annual review and of
course your self-evaluation. Um this is
the um let's see I think this is the
eighth self-evaluation that uh we all
have engaged in together. Um you've been
doing this for two years now um under
the um under the current order with uh
Texas Education Agency. And so um the
expectation for the board in your order
is that you have um that you get you get
to the meets focus level um on your
self-evaluation which is 60 points and
the [clears throat] board actually
accomplished that um not last April but
the April before so April of 2024. Um so
you need to um the expectation was to
get there and then to maintain it uh to
maintain that status for um three
consecutive quarters and uh you have
done that and it uh when you completed
that um third consecutive quarter or
technically the fourth consecutive
quarter um I I met with a representative
from the Texas Education Agency and uh
we calibrated the results and um you
with a little bit of feedback just to
ensure that um you're able to sustain
this work. Uh
you all have implemented you've made
adjustments based on that feedback over
this past quarter and now uh this is um
hopefully the the end of the road um
with um with this this part of the
order. This should be the final um the
the final um thing that you need to do
uh to meet this part of the exit
criteria. Um specifically that
maintaining uh meets focus for um three
conse four four consecutive quarters
which technically this is now your fifth
consecutive quarter.
>> Thank you.
Um and then Ashley, can you share a
little bit about how we're going to use
um the annual report in the training we
do on Saturday?
>> Yes. So on Saturday um
so on Saturday we will uh talk we will
um begin our workshop uh with an
opportunity to uh reflect on um this
past 12 months and uh you know I will
give you some opportunities to um
reflect on the work um so the board as a
whole so the board is a an entity will
engage in that conversation tonight on
Saturday um we'll have a more structured
discussion in executive session and it's
in executive session because you will um
talk about some of the um you know
you'll reflect on um individual
performance individual
um you know individual behaviors and so
um you know we we have that conversation
in executive session because it is um
part of your per you all you all are
officers of the district and you are
considered personel
Um and so
that is an appropriate conversation to
have in executive session. When we
complete um when we complete that
conversation, we'll come back into open
session and the board uh all of the
board members will have an opportunity
to share their reflections um in in that
public forum if if you so wish.
>> Thank you for that. Um
do you do we want to talk about the um
scoring on the self-evaluation
and how it differs because there are a
couple of things that differed because
we changed the monitoring calendar.
There are a couple of things that
um are different.
>> Yes. So um in uh pre last month your
self-evaluation score was 74 points. um
you made some adjustments to your
monitoring calendar uh this past quarter
and so um just because of that temp
temporary adjustment uh so because of
that adjustment your score uh will drop
um just by three points uh temporarily
that will come back up immediately in
your next quarter if you uh choose to
continue self-evaluating
um on a quarterly basis at that point.
Um so that was the first one. There was
one other area where there was um so I
think the majority of the board had um
had given you had assigned nine points
for um the the last section I think I
believe synergy and teamwork. Um and
that that was to um com [clears throat]
so the uh descriptor is that the the
board rather than uh the superintendent
um and administration
uh completes the majority of Lonear
governance tasks and so um you you have
definitely begun to transition into
doing that. Uh, Secretary Gonzalez has
uh met uh met with me and uh your
administrative team for the last couple
of months and done some calibration and
so um we definitely are in on the right
track for being able to do that. Um but
we still have a couple of other a couple
of additional things that the board
really needs to take ownership of. One
of them being uh to facilitate the
self-evaluation process.
>> Thank you.
Um I also want a point of clarity that I
think is really uh important to note. I
want to give credit to all of my
colleagues and to you as our coach. Um I
think we have done this for six extra
quarters now. So it's our first quarter.
We owed three and then we've had three
more. So we've had a full seven quarters
of meets. Um so uh credit to everyone
who has done the work to meet our order
uh very very diligently and with great
seriousness um and to really lean into
this work to make sure those things were
happening. So thank you. Um trustees, do
we have questions uh comments about
this?
Trusty Hunter and then we'll go to
Trusty Gonzalez. Thank you.
>> Thank you. I'm so sorry.
>> Um I just have a clarification. Um
there's a a great deal of concern in our
community um as we continue to monitor
our time and as we've been doing this
you said now for seven quart you said
seven
>> yes
>> seven um
>> hit meets for seven quarters
>> we've hit meets for seven quarters for
eight we um have a better understanding
but when we explain to our community
that uh talking about say turnaround
plans or the activity even that we're
going to do on Saturday does not count
do you perhaps have a um more cogent way
of explaining that so that we can carry
that forward to our communities.
>> Yes, and that's actually a great
question. Um so
I think the uh the best place to start
uh in answering that question uh is um
why do we talk so why do we encourage
school boards to spend uh the majority
of their time in board meetings talking
about student outcomes? Any
ideas, Ward?
>> Um I'm not sure what you're referencing.
Do you mean um the adult action student?
Is that what you're talking about?
>> Yeah. So um so the expectation that LSG
sets forth um and what is set forth in
the um in the order is to spend 50% of
your time uh focusing on student
outcomes in your board meeting. Um and
it's been it's been a while since we've
talked about this. So it's it's fine if
no one if no one remembers. Um but my
the question that I asked is uh why do
we encourage that? Why why is that the
recommendation?
>> It's because um that's why school
districts that's why schools exist is
>> that's why school systems exist out
school systems exist to improve student
outcomes. And so um that's that's
because that is why school systems
exist. school boards exist to represent
the vision and values of the community
as it relates to student outcomes. Um
the way that you're going to um do that
most effectively is by spending the
majority of your time focused on those
things. And so um when we talk about
focusing on student outcomes, we're
specifically talking about the items
that are um directly related to student
outcomes. So actually not directly
related to student outcomes that
directly are student outcomes. So things
that students know and things that
students are able to do, those are
student outcomes. Everything else that
the school system does is important, but
the student outcome student outcomes are
the reason that school systems exist.
And so um by spending your time, at
least 50% of it, uh focusing on student
outcomes, uh that is how you are
communicating your priorities to the
community. That's how you are um
actually driving administrative action
but by the things that you are um
discussing in your board meetings. Now
that's not to suggest that the other 50%
of time isn't important. It actually is
critically important as you all have um
communicated and demonstrated tonight.
And so, um, you know, I think last month
your, um, your your time use was 77%.
Which is incredible. Um, but the
expectation isn't 77, it's 50%. I also
understand that, um, [clears throat]
that was to kind of build up some time
so that you can also, uh, focus on some
of those other things, uh, in the coming
months. Um, so it's very actually
extremely smart for the board to budget
your time in that way. Um, but all of
the things that are related to student
outcomes, so turnaround plans, budgets,
consolidations, all of those things are
critically important, but they
themselves are not student outcomes.
Um
I want to make I want to pause for a
second before I um I have one other
thing to add about um the workshop on
Saturday and that time use. But before I
go there, are there any um questions
about other questions about this um idea
about student outcomes specifically?
>> No, thank you. I appreciate that. Thank
you so much.
>> Yeah. And just a clarification on
Saturday. Um, so the majority of our
time on Saturday actually will be
counted towards student outcomes and uh
the time so the time during the lonear
governance workshop um the time that is
in executive session will um it will not
be counted because it's not uh public
meeting time. It's not board authorized
public meeting time. Um, so nothing will
um none of those things will count as
other.
So Ashley, can you um just clarify that
a little more?
So the time in executive session will
not count toward our our required time
or our high leverage time.
>> Correct. Um
correct because um actually you know
what that's not that's not true. Okay.
Because it's we do high leverage time
because it's uh because it's uh
self-evaluation.
So it's different from a regular
>> all of our all of our time together. I
know you've got another small section
that you're going to do some additional
training. Um that will be other but
every the rest of our time together will
be um it it will count towards student
outcomes.
>> So our executive session and the open
part all of it will.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. That's good to know. Thank you.
That makes more sense. I was trying to
figure out why that wasn't and that
makes a whole lot more sense now. Thank
you for that. I appreciate that.
>> Yeah. Um, Trusty Gonzalez, did you have
a question or does anyone else have
>> I just wanted to say that I've had the
chance to facilitate one of the revised
2-way engagement sessions with trustee
Singh and I received a lot of positive
feedback about the more specific campus
data. um that's a part of the
presentation so that it's not looking at
the goal progress um in totality as a
district but it's more relevant to the
conversation on that specific campus. I
did have a question um given the
revisions that we voted on to the
scorecard and um the removal of goals
that are related specifically to uh
middle school performance. If we had
two-way engagement meetings at middle
schools, is there information? Is there
data that you would suggest recommend to
to maintain that relevance at the campus
level?
>> Yeah. Um so even even in middle school,
there are um indicators that contribute
to the CCMR goal. Um and then your uh
first and second or so your first and
second goals that are specific to third
grade. Um you know that those goals are
actually um you're focusing on student
outcomes um that are going to actually
so if students improve in those areas
then they are uh more likely to be
successful in middle school. So you're
actually bolstering uh the middle school
experience by um by uh improving upon um
the learning that is happening in
elementary school. And so for each grade
level, you're actually um all of the
goals are relevant for all of the grade
levels, but um specifically
you're building building upon um you
know, middle school with those early um
uh early learning goals and then um
middle school really is going to be the
bridge between uh goals one and two and
goal three. So, I think that it is
absolutely appropriate to still discuss
those um because you're um
you're you're creating those those
opportunities for those students.
>> Thank you. That was all. Thank you.
>> Thank you for that. And I have um a
follow-up question to that which is if
we are going to add I think we're
getting kind of near the end of that
first wave that we plan to do. we were
focusing on our campuses um with two
unacceptable ratings and we're getting
near the end of that and I think there's
appetite for doing more. I think you
know some of our middle schools we know
that our middle middle schools as so
many middle schools are kind of in a
unique spot. Do we need to reapprove a
calendar? Do we just add that to a web
page? How what does that formal process
look like and what are the expectations?
Yeah. So, um, so, um, my recommendation
is to go ahead and add them and even if
you need to, um, go back and approve
them retroactively as a board, um, the
board taking that action as an entity
saying these are like th this is our th
this is board-ledd um, engagement. the
this is these people, these board
members um they are authorized by the
board to go and speak for the board at
these meetings. Um
it's just a a an extra step to um to
reinforce like this is our shared
message and we'll speak uh we'll speak
to that much more on Saturday.
>> Thank you. So to clarify, we could
schedule more phone November and then
approve them at our November voting
meeting even though some of them will
have already happened by then.
>> Yeah, that that's totally fine.
>> Thank you. That's helpful.
>> Trusty Singh has a followup.
>> If we wanted to um it's been a while
since we did the staff the boardled
staff two-way community engagement and I
would love and especially since we have
changed the scorecard a bit. We haven't
done it with the newer revision. So, um,
Ashley, I'm seeing your face. So, like,
yes, we could do that as well.
>> Um, yeah,
>> and schedule that as well. Okay.
>> You, you all, you all get to define who
your community is. And so, I you are
never going to hear me say no, don't go
engage those people. Um, it's my
perspective. The more engagement you do,
the the better it is for Austin ISD.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Uh, do we have additional
questions or clarifications?
All right. Um, Ashley, thank you so much
for being with us. I appreciate it. Um,
>> thank you for your guidance uh to help
us take this very very seriously
um for a very long time. uh really
appreciate um the stakes are high for a
lot of reasons and um we really um you
helped us lean in and do all that was
required and I really really appreciate
it very much. So um
>> I am I am uh privileged to be to be on
the journey with you all and I look
forward to seeing you all in just a
couple of days in person.
>> Yes, we we have a a long packed day
together so uh looking forward to it.
Thank you for making the trip to be with
us. I appreciate it. Have a good night.
Um, all right. So, we're going to move
to items for a separate vote for this.
We have taken motions on this. Uh, is
there any further discussion beyond uh
what Ashley was here to share?
All right. Um, so having a motion by
Secretary Gonzalez and a second now I've
forgotten by Trustee Kintana. Okay,
thank you to approve item 4.1.
All in favor, please raise your right
hand.
Thank you. Um, and the motion passes by
all those on the dis. Thank you. uh and
anyone who wants to go look can see the
annual evaluation which is a big
narrative of all of the lonear
governance things we have done this year
with a lot of explanation and data and
all kinds of things. So thank you for
that. Um Secretary Gonzalez, do we have
a motion to approve item 14.2?
>> Yes, I move to approve item 14.2
issuance tax and revenue anticipation
note.
>> Um is there a second?
>> Second. Okay, trustees. Any further
discussion on this item? This is the
loan that we talked about
um with Miss Montgomery earlier.
All right. Uh having a motion by
Secretary Gonzalez and a second by
Trustee Kintana to approve item 14.2.
All in favor, please raise your right
hand.
And the motion passes by all those on
the dis. Uh, we will now recess our open
meeting at 8:09 p.m. and move to
executive session pursuant to Texas
Government Code sections 551.074,
551.072, 551.073,
551.087,
5551.076,
551.0821
and 551.071.
When we finish with the executive
session, we will briefly return to the
open session to formally adjourn the
meeting. and the adjournment will be
recorded and included in all replays of
tonight's meeting. Thank you for joining
us and have a good evening.
We will now reconvene the open meeting
at 10:14 p.m.
Secretary Gonzalez, do I have a motion
to adjourn the meeting?
>> So moved.
>> The meeting is adjourned at 10:14 p.m.
Thank you.